[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
a overview video for the new course on
chess about a complete repertoire
against 1.d4 based on the nimzo-indian
and there were cows in variation of the
Queen's Gambit it covers all sidelines
as well so we have a full repertoire
against 1.d4 and even one against one
Knight f3 this is an added bonus
before we go into details of this
repertoire and the whole concept behind
it I'd like to introduce the two authors
this is the cooperation between freedom
arts and Daniel barish from South Africa
he's rated roughly two thousand three
hundred seventy I think and the newest
rating list and the moment that this
video was produced as early September
2019 and and me I'm international Master
Quest of zelicah from Germany I'm rated
2430 something and have already produced
a number of products for chasuble and
other website and I might also be known
to us such as explain for my youtube
channel Daniel has recently scored his
first international master norm on the
way of doing that he beat a couple of
grandmasters with this repertoire so it
has been tried and tested already
extensively by him this product in this
cooperation um yeah got on the way after
I asked the chasuble officials my
contact person's about a new mini
repertoire that I could probably produce
and they said to me you know we already
have one in the works
Daniel has started to work on that and
doing this like doing to repertoire
makes no sense
is it maybe an idea if you work together
on that and then we got into contact and
um the product that we now have is a
cooperation between us and we decided
that I should do the presentation at the
end because I just have plenty of
experience doing that so it felt like
the natural way to do it um
this is a full repertoire me against 1d
for this is important to emphasize so
after d4 let me play Knight f6 and even
if white now plays moves like a Bishop
f4 Knight f3 Knight c3 whatever these
are all covered in this repertoire the
main um part of it however are the main
lines and the main lines are main lines
for reasons they are played mainly and
therefore c4 e6 is you have the turning
point here for this or this repertoire
is white may play Knight c3 after which
we play the nimzo-indian a very
well-established main an opening that is
played by basically all the top players
almost all of them we have some some
cases who are playing more g6 based
systems but the names o is kind of an
evergreen opening and basically also
everybody agrees every theoretician or
strong player that it is a very good
opening there's really no debate about
that the challenge a little bit is to
find a partner opening for the names oh
yes wide very often plays Knight f3
because he maybe does not want to
challenge black in the name zone and
after 90 of 3 Black has a very wide
choice but our choice I think is a very
logical one as it gives the game a
distinct flavor of animism we played d5
it looks like a Queen's game and it is
technically a Queen's Gambit but after
Knight c3 which is by far the most
commonly seen move we play Bishop before
as well
and we combine ideas of the nihms oh and
Queen's Gambit in that way this is the
so-called Rico's in variation and this
is a variation that has gained a lot of
ground in the last let's say two decades
in an top level chess many many top
players play that we have Magnus Carlsen
playing it um this is some just just one
example I'm just thinking about it I
mean I think
almost everybody is playing it here
Wesley so is playing it many many top
grandmasters the attraction of the
Rogozin is that it combines the solidity
of the Queen's Gambit it's a classical
opening with a pawn Center but it
combines it with a little bit of
sharpness due to this early pin and
oftentimes we get some play with the c5
Queen a5 it's a little bit more
challenging maybe to play then the more
conservative Bishop d7 move at this
point um in this some repertoire we also
cover the Catalan very popular opening
and nowadays on the top level but it
also gets to be played on the amateur
level more and more we also go Bishop
before I am making this quite a
consistent choice of putting the bishop
on to that square the idea is that we
misplace the Bishop a little bit and go
back to e7 again this is a line that
that is played by all the top players so
we can always side Magnus he has a very
classical repertoire against one d4 with
the nihms oh and Queen's Gambit um and
as he has played on multiple occasions
but again you can also look at people
like a roni on everybody has played it
so a very good opening variation what we
also covered is a repertoire against
Knight f3 because if you select
something against Knight f3 you have to
keep in mind what you play against d4
because why it might still play d4 very
early on and here our suggestion is to
play d5 as we already know it's not
going to be in him so he has a knight
only 3 therefore we start the 5 and we
are ready to transpose like this into
the Ragusan again if white chooses to to
do so but we will also cover some ideas
against moves like G 3 C 4 B 3 and so on
so you will be able to fight against one
d4 if you get and learn this repertoire
and also against one night F
three against e4 it is not as easy to
get to the lines presented there are
some ideas but it's not and as an easy
task as it is against Knight f3 so this
is a good starting point for you to add
to this fantastic opening like the names
oh and there it goes into your
repertoire it's something that is also I
think going to be very valuable in the
long run and the reason is that the
Newman's Own in particular is extremely
flexible we don't have yet committed our
pawns here and very often we will play
with d5 in this repertoire to get some
similar type of positions after Knight
f3
we will transpose for example
immediately to the rogozin and after e3
we will also play a quick defy for a
similarly flavoured position but in the
very long run you can even say ok this
is good I know the names o and then know
how the names O is combined with d5 but
there are also other variations you can
for example quite often play without the
D pawn play with b6 play with c5 oops
they will see 5 it's a very flexible
opening so it's an extremely good thing
to know in the long run because it is
something that you can use over a long
period of time and you can add some
variety within the opening I think this
is very important if you learn other
openings that will have the same pawn
structure every single time it is almost
sure that at some point at some point
you are bored with it and you want to do
something else until you can play the
names of all the time and later add some
new interesting lines to your repertoire
if you desire to do so this is for
example why I have written a book on the
names of some years ago in 2015 and we
have absolutely have almost zero overlap
between this repertoire on the names oh
and the one that I presented in my book
you can basically play the opening and
such a different way that there's no
overlap so even within the names though
you have many many options yeah I hope
you I
interested in in the course I think it's
a very good way to play I have played
the new mezzo and Rogozin quite a bit
over the years through grows and not so
much in recent years I didn't get 93 or
that often but the Newman so has been a
mainstay of my opening repertoire or for
a very long time I hope you enjoyed the
intro video and yeah much success with
employing those interesting openings
thanks for watching
[Music]